Rupert Murdoch was threatened personally
by Tucker because his fiance was saying
he was a prophet and then the wedding
broke off and then Tucker gets fired
there's uh the fiance said Tucker is a
prophet that was one of the news reports
that came out that apparently they had a
dinner then Rupert Murdoch's you know
fiance saying like oh he's a he's a
prophet he's a genius oh God then a
month later he's like yeah I'm the
prophet yeah I think from a business
perspective if you own a brand and then
you hire a personality and the
personality is becoming bigger than the
brand any CEO is going to get rid of
that that person's a threat to their
brain that's that's it you think so
I don't know any Murdoch my view would
be that Murdock is saying Fox News is
the company if we're at a point where
people are saying Fox News is doomed
because of one man that man should not
be at this company even if it means it
hurts us in the short term in the long
term Fox News needs to stand on its own